Hello and welcome to this presentation.
My name is Munir. I am the CEO and
co-founder of Porsche AI. Um I'm here to
share a bit about my journey as a a
relatively recent founder of an AI
startup coming out of a variety of of
roles especially in product at big tech
most recently Stripe and for that Google
and Amazon. Um I'm hoping that this the
presentation uh is useful in particular
for people who want to make that leap
and start their own company or people
who are in a similar space sort of uh uh
stage as me uh starting their own
company in AI at the moment um and and
hopefully you'll take some some useful
notes from this. So uh before jumping in
very briefly um I have done a variety of
roles I mentioned in big tech in
particular u always based out of here in
London. Um so I launched the deals uh
program of Amazon in the UK. It's the
thing that they use to run Black Friday
prime day and all these big deals driven
events. Uh I launched and grew Google
pay and 30 markets in AMIA and I led
most recently bank as a service uh at
Stripe for AMIA as well. But at some
point I always wanted to do my own thing
and at some point I felt like um you
know like I really need to to get to it
and I felt like nothing else made sense
anymore and that frankly I felt a bit
like a copout. I felt like damn it I
need to do this. Um and so fast forward
to whatever it was June last year so a
year ago um Porsche AI became that that
thing that uh that I started with my
co-founder Emma that I met at Stripe. Uh
it's an open source SDK for building
production agents um with a focus on
regulated industries. And I'm not going
to dwell too much on what Porsche itself
does because it's not really what we're
here to talk about. There'll be a link
at the end of this presentation uh if
you're interested to learn more about
the product itself, which I hope you
will be. Um but anyways, let's let's
focus on uh on the current topic. So,
let me share what what I learned so far.
And I hope you find this useful. And I'd
love to to hear your thoughts on it in
in the comments as well. Uh, first thing
I want to talk about is what what user
problems and user discovery feels like
uh at the moment and how freaking
different that is from what I've done
what I've seen so far. Uh, I'm going to
use a lot of video I'm a gamer. I'm
going to use a lot of video game
analogies
um to to describe this. I hope some of
you can relate to it and find it find it
a bit fun. Um, but like the first thing
I'll say is normally user problems are
they have some shape to them, right? And
they have some adjacency to other user
problems you you're used to. You're at
Stripe, you do payment products and a
user wants to do card issuance to u you
know use the money that they have in
their Stripe balance. I mean, it's
there's some adjacency, something to
anchor to. Uh, in the current setup,
partly because it's a startup, you're
going from zero to one, and partly
because it's AI, it really feels like
that first time you try out a a sort of
Soulslike game. And I'm using here a
screenshot from Neo, which is one of the
worst ones at that particular challenge.
And you're trying to configure your
character and you can't figure out how
to how to combine the gear. you sort of
directionally know that the stats all
need to go up, but you don't know what
how to how to get there. Uh, right. And
so nothing makes sense at first. And
this is a bit what AI feels like for the
moment because users don't really know
what their problems are. They sort of
know that they want to use AI and they
know that there's some opportunity
there, but they don't the user problems
are almost like an emergent property of
the space. They are not defined yet. Um,
and what is possible and what the
technology allows you to do is changing
very quickly. And so instead of your
more conventional three month or six
month road map that you sort of revisit,
um you just have to make directional
bests and iterate very fast on them um
through putting products out there and
looking at the user reaction. And so
your your your anchor for you and the
rest of your team is is really just
hypothesisdriven
um deliberate iteration. That's the bit
that gives you the focus that you need
as opposed to you know the conventional
road maps that we're used to in the
trade.
Um the other thing is like uh all this
like this really reassuring
uh idea of using uh user storyboards and
having sort of user critical user
journeys for your pain points etc that
you can anchor on. uh those things all
sort of feel like they go out the window
to to a large extent. And so it feels
like for those of you who have tried
that game No Man's Sky where like you
start the game and you're like huh like
what am I what's the story arc? What am
I what's the mission? What am I supposed
to do next? And instead you really are
creating your own narrative here. Um and
so this oper this you really have to
stretch that muscle where you have to
help your users out of that initial
inertia of trying AI for their you know
if you're in a particular vertical or
you're horizontal for a specific use
case. Um and you have to work with them
to create those narratives and help them
anchor on a use case. Uh and once you're
there, you're starting to gra to
gradually move to more familiar
territory where you're iterating with
them on the use case and you have
something to anchor on where you can
refine your product against that use
case and the problems that it the the
challenges that that brings. Um and
that's a bit like when you start
colonizing the planet in No Man's Sky as
well. So you sort of start to to know
what your actual problems are uh and and
have a more tangible problems and more
more scoped problem space to work with.
Uh and that's that's an opportunity and
a challenge at the same time of course.
Um the third thing I wanted to to talk
about is uh I actually love that bit and
that's probably my favorite bit. It's
just how gratifying the product
development process is because you know
unlike this sort of sensation of hurting
lemmings that you get from having to
like speak to 100 different departments
and get 100 different sign offs on your
product design and your engineering
design before and your API design before
you can go and launch the damn thing.
here you're sort of in the span of a few
hours if if not a few days uh you'll go
from like something happened like MCP is
out and becoming a standard you go from
that to having an idea a spec um a
product spec an design
um some testing and release uh in a very
short period of time and it's just
amazing to see to see that stuff go from
your head into into code and into and
into the wild so quickly uh it's
exhilarating It is worth noting though
that like in particular in AI, velocity
is like a table sticks. It's not a nice
to have or or something you pat on your
back on your back for. Uh you you're out
of the game if you can't if you can't
release quickly and release well. Um and
that's because some of the opportunities
that allow you to stand out and and sort
of get those power ups that accelerate
you uh like good old Mario here um they
come and go very quickly. Again, I
always go back to MCP uh when it had a
moment, but you can think of agent to
agent protocol. You can think of
diffusion models. All of these are
moments that come up. And it's important
that you're able to react and build
products that uh that are uh at the
forefront when it comes to these to
these trends and to these breakthroughs,
technology breakthroughs. uh to
basically continue to grow your brand
and and cement cement yourself in the
developer community or in the user
community more generally uh whatever
your target customer segment is.
[Music]
Um, lastly, and this is my god, this is
like the toughest part for me, uh, if
I'm honest. Um, but also where I'm
learning the most,
um, is something I have to admit I
really underestimated how difficult that
bit would be. And that's like how little
scaffolding you have around you when
you're when you're doing your own thing
from scratch when it comes to sort of
outreach, awareness, traffic, adoption,
right? And uh we're in the middle of
like full-on hype and meme wars in the
AI space. Uh and it's hard to tell
signal from noise. And so in that
particular race and without any of the
sort of uh advantages of of being
attached to a bigger brand, uh it feels
like you're playing Crash Bandicoot but
without any of the boosters. Or if
you're more familiar with Mario Kart,
you're playing Mario Kart, but you don't
have any of those uh red and green
turtles to fire at your friends. so you
can beat them. Uh so uh this for me has
been like the steepest learning curve.
Um and so one of those is for example
that that you that you learn is that
people follow people primarily, right?
And and then if you were launching a
product at Stripe, all it takes is a
tweak a tweet from one of the colison or
one of their seconds in command and you
know people know about your product and
and start reaching out and and you're
you're off to the races as they say. uh
whereas in this case you have to find
advocates you have to find credible
voices in the industry to speak for you
uh and to use their platform to talk
about you and act as as force
multipliers. Um the other thing is in
terms of just brand awareness and
traffic um you don't have the advantage
of of the like I said this sort of brand
association and and the website and the
other channels of uh of a broader
company right and so the way you the way
you deal with that is you find allies
and those will be either startups at the
same stage or startups that are slightly
ahead but that are interested in the
space you're working on and where they
see synergy. You find ways of
partnering, cross marketing,
cross-selling, even things like getting
your docs to show up in the um getting
your product to show up in the
integration docs of some company like
browser base, for example, uh is a
significant channel to get people to
then land on your properties, your
website, your GitHub repo, and and start
discovering your product. Um and so I,
you know, we're getting pretty beat up
there. I'm getting pretty beat up on on
that front and and
uh and even in some cases not not doing
as well as I would like but also
learning a ton and so it's it's part of
why I put myself out there. It's to sort
of uh really stretch myself and so u I'm
sure we'll figure it out but it's been
it's definitely been a challenge and a
massive learning curve. U so I wanted to
call that out. Uh so there you have it.
I won't take much longer of uh of your
time. If you made it this far, I really
appreciate you listening. I hope that
you find this useful. I would love to
hear from you. Uh not just in the
comments down below, but if you want to
reach out on LinkedIn, have a chat about
your experience. If you're trying to
make that leap and you think a
conversation would be helpful, uh you
know where to find me uh on LinkedIn, I
mean.
Um and uh and look, I'm no I'm no
expert. I'm still learning. The idea,
the purpose of this of this
uh talk is to just uh share my
experience and and for it to maybe act
as inspiration or get you thinking about
what that looks like for you. Um if you
like the content of this video, the only
thing that I ask if you can find it in
you is to scan this QR code and land on
our GitHub repository. Um and uh if you
would kindly give us a star, that goes
um a very long way. Um, thank you for
listening. Thank you for making it that
far. And um, whoever you are, I hope
you're well and I hope we one day meet
in person. Thank you very